welcome to this video playing am with
his name Combinator 35 p.m. Dugan Rehan
to for something ok it's a new opponent
and the only good thing is when you lost
five games in a row your rating is
really low and you start to get points
in many situations if you win then I
still have to score and he's relatively
high rated so the 60 is possible ok III
that's a rare line not not bad so let's
get c5 in age 6 to prevent any Bishop g5
ideas
yep trying to try to play quickly him
not to try to avoid any any time issues
interesting setup that he played IAM
with night up to d5 and so on quite
interesting yeah a 3d three those kind
of slow ish lines they get fashionable
and are they're interesting giving the
game will light slightly and slightly
different different flavor so what do I
do it's very annoying at this piece
there
difficult to get rid get rid of
now white white seems a bit more
comfortable here don't don't know how to
get rid of this night I mean I can do 97
maybe 97 b6 it might be an idea possibly
for night a form their white is a bit
better him it's just just more active
yeah this was one of the moves I thought
were possible yeah i was thinking this
is probably a bit better for wide still
but at least I'm getting a little bit of
relief by trades night if I have okay as
Roxy one rook c 1 to c 7 this kind of
thing so maybe here in Roxy aid
it's ready for Luke see hmm no f5 oh so
that's an aggressive way to do it hmm a
ticket is Bishop will take it's not
looking any good hmm
maybe this for 96 and then I have some
retweet squares still knight c6
yeah take it Bishop takes I'm basically
basically lost so i have to move the
Bishop Bishop d7 or bishop CA a time
going here night only five is nice but
his pieces are very active so it should
be good for my team somehow I'm not
quite sure with what precise moves on ok
he's going for a direct tactic if I take
it Knight f6 is killing me nice so I'm
going putting the night down ok he got
the pawn but at least i have e5 as a
good square now threatens Knight f6
Bishop g7 for mate ok this is a good fun
this game great remarkable
just lost what can you do and plated
well I play badly everything falls into
places some can check check on edge form
and I probably there's some winning
tactic I don't see it at the moment but
it's for him to find yeah I thought
maybe Knight f6 this is possible maybe
Knight f6 takes bishop f7 could be a
winning tactic
if he's not doing that that the capture
doesn't make much sense to be honest
check okay maybe maybe there's a winning
tactic as well but I don't see it ok
Knight f6 check as the threat hmm cannot
really cover that I can check him here
it doesn't help really here don't
check check yeah thats that is the
winner check check yeah five more can I
do that is a 6 loss in a row black
resigns very very nicely played though I
just he just outplayed me in this game
just outplayed me damn around here white
is slightly better and it seemed all
very very logical it's very difficult to
get rid of this knight on d5 it's not a
very that's not a very comfortable
position maybe yeah the computer
suggests to just take it and go here and
white white is better what is better
here at least a little bit it's probably
still better than this the engines is
just this ok and then oops sorry and
then taking on before that that I did
not really think about now it's very
logical yeah this is giving away upon
computers has cleared Vantage from black
hard to believe but ok and here why this
better mean I hope that my knight to e5
is an idea or something f4 is strong and
I'm out of ideas f5 is good and now
Bishop h6 just played very strong chest
Queen g3 is strong push a reform yeah
check yeah I had this had the suspicion
that this is already a win and it is
it's actually made I didn't calculate it
properly but this is the mating idea or
queen g8 Queen g6 mate
so on jung poo six in a row quite quite
amazing okay out of the six games that I
lost I killed my seven two or three
games when I was sometimes even better
but this was really really well deserved
well deserved lost their played it
varies very strong very strong way Chuck
can you do thanks for watching guys